in this video we're going to talk about
parallel lines cut by a transversal and
we're going to go through four examples
about how to solve for various angles
and some different diagrams so let's
dive in the first thing we want to just
kind of review briefly is you know what
are corresponding angles and alternate
interior angles alternate exterior and
consecutive interior and what does that
mean when there's parallel lines
involved well when you have parallel
lines you'll notice that they put a
little arrow here somewhere like in the
middle of the line not at the ends of
the lines and that indicates that the
lines are parallel but when you have
this third line that cuts across those
two lines that's what's called a
transversal it transverses or cuts
across and you get these eight angles
that are formed and what we call
corresponding angles you can think of
this as forming like an X see this x
here up at the top and there's kind of
like an X here down at the bottom if I
was to pick this x up and slide it down
the angles that match up with one
another those are called corresponding
angles and they're going to be congruent
to one another so for example two would
be equal to six or one is equal to five
so sometimes what I think is like lower
leftand corner matches up with lower
leftand corner or lower right lower
right now again this only works though
if the lines are parallel and they're
cut by that transversal so that's called
the corresponding angles theorem now
alternate interior angles if you look
closely at the name it kind of tells you
a little bit about it interior means the
angles that are in between the parallel
lines like 3 4 5 and six but alternate
is like a nod to the fact that one of
the angles is on the left and the other
angle is on the right they are in
alternate sides so when you think of
alternate interior that could be like
three and six like see these two angles
are congruent and four and five those
two angles are congruent they have the
same angle measure so that's the
alternate interior angles theorem now
the alternate exterior angles theorem
exterior means that the angles are
outside the parallel lines not in
between like the interior angles and and
Alternate means that one's on the right
one's on the left so these would be
alternate exterior angles they're
congruent these would be alternate
exterior angles they're congruent and
then the last one we want to talk about
is the consecutive interior angles
theorem and that's again the two angles
that are in between the two parallel
lines but they're on the same side so
some teachers or books or classes will
call the same side interior angle
theorem and this is kind of the Oddball
of the group in the sense that those two
angles are supplementary they add up to
180° are not congruent so these ones add
up to 180 and these two here would add
up to 180 so for example four and six or
3 and five so let's dive into our four
examples in practice this first example
we're trying to find out what x is in
this diagram and they give us that this
angle here is 50° this angle over here
is 2x - 6 now there's more than one way
to do these problems but what I can do
is one of two things one thing I can do
is that I have vertical angles so
whenever you see two lines that
intersect they form like an X those
angles that are across from each other
are going to be congruent so these two
are equal and these two are equal that's
vertical
angles and so if I know this angle is 2x
- 6 I know that this angle right here is
2x - 6 across from it by the vertical
angles
theorem but what do I know about these
two angles well I can see that they're
on the same side of the transversal
they're in between the two parallel
lines that's what we just talked about
with the consecutive interior angles
theorem and I know that these angles are
going to be supplementary remember this
is the odd one of the group all these
other ones they're congruent these ones
are supplementary so I can write a
little equation I can say uh 2x - 6 + 50
is equal to 180 so that's 2x + 44 is
equal to 180 I can subtract 44 so just a
little bit of algebra here right and
that comes out to 2x is = to
136 and if we divide both sides by two X
is equal to
68 and we solved it okay let's look at
number two now so number two is
interesting because we have three
parallel lines right cut by these two
transversals and we want to find out the
value of X and Y so let's take a look at
this problem here so it looks like we've
got this angle and this angle and
sometimes what you want to do is kind of
block out the angles that you're not
using so you can see here's two parallel
lines cut by a transversal these angles
are in between the parallel lines but
one's on the left one's on the right
those are what we call alternate
interior angles and they're congruent so
that means if this is 150 x here has to
be
150 and what we can also do is we can
look at kind of ignore this Middle Line
okay we've got these two parallel lines
this angle and this angle are
consecutive interior meaning they're
going to be supplementary so if this is
150 that means this angle here is 30
30 and whenever you see a straight line
you can think of that as a straight
angle and that that's going to be 180°
so if I was to take y + 10 + 30 + 30
that has to add up to 180 because see
that straight line so we've got y + 10 +
30 plus another 30 = 180 and let's solve
that so we've got y + 70 = 180 subtract
70 and we're getting
110 is the value of y let's take a look
at two more examples okay let's try
number three if you want to pause the
video and try these on your own go ahead
and we'll go through them together but
for number three notice we've got these
two parallel lines which I should have
indicated over here as well uh but we're
trying to solve for this missing angle X
right there so how would we do that well
using our theorems that we talked about
earlier what do we know about uh this
angle
and this angle well these are alternate
exterior angles so see the parallel
lines see the transversal one's on the
right one's on the left those angles are
going to be congruent to one another so
that's 40 we also know that if this is
45 using that alternate exterior angles
theorem this angle is going to be 45
okay and then now we can see we have a
straight line all these angles have to
add up to 180 right so we have 40 + 45 +
x = 180
that's 85 + x = 180 subtract the 85 from
both
sides and we can see that X is equal to
95° and we solved it let's look at
number four this one what do we know
about these angles well we don't have a
theorem for those two angles but we do
know that this angle in the lower right
hand corner of this a and this angle in
the lower right hand corner of this a
are congruent by our corresponding
angles theorem right they would
correspond or match up if I slide that X
right up there so we've got 12x + 60 and
these two angles you can see they form a
linear pair so linear means like a line
pair means like a pair of shoes like two
and those two angles they're going to be
supplementary they're going to add up to
180 or they're going to form that
straight angle or that line so that's
called a linear pair so let's go ahead
and make an equation let's see we've got
2x + 20 + 12x + 60 is equal to that
straight angle 180 so let's see we've
got I'll call this
2.5x plus
80 is equal to 180 let's subtract 80
from both sides that's going to give us
100 = 2.5x divide both sides by
2.5 and what's 100 divided by 2.5 is it
40 yeah it's 40 so you got X is equal to
40 and you solved it if you like the
these videos about geometry which a lot
of people don't uh cover check out my
geometry playlist I've got a geometry
course playlist it's about 11 videos it
takes you through a typical geometry
course gets into the theory and the
practice and the examples I'll put a
link or I'll try to put a link right
there and uh follow me over that and
check out those videos I'll see you over
there